everyone
right good evening members and officers
of the council
member of the press and public I welcome
you to this meeting the council which
indeed is my very last
after having served four years
I shall miss you all and all of it
now then if the fire alarm is activated
please vacate the officers via the
stairs either through the security door
to my right or opposite the lift in the
foyer please do not use the lifts please
assemble in Hawley Square on the green
officers will assist you and advise
winners as deemed safe to return to the
chamber
with respect to filming of the meeting I
would advise that a filming takes place
anyone in attendance in the public areas
may have their image captured I urge
anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present does anyone intend to film a
meeting
I don't see anyone indicating any film
you're recording will not be permitted
for any item of business were exempt or
confidential information
is considered following the exclusion
the press and public from the meeting
with restrictions on the use of mobile
phones would everyone present please
ensure that their mobile phones are
turned to silent and they are not used
to make or receive phone calls whilst in
this meeting or indeed while the meeting
is in progress
I should do that off by heart really
shouldn't I
now then agenda item one election of
chair are there any nominations
I have cancer cup indicated but
councilor Everett as well I'll take
councilor Cup first because I did see
him first
thank you chair uh please can I nominate
councilor Paul Moore
thank you very much indeed noted
do you have a second for that counselor
cup
who was that thank you councilor Everett
I nominate councilor John Edwards thank
you very much do you have a seconder
thank you very much indeed
right are there any other candidates
I don't see any other nominations
right are there has no other coincidence
uh well we could help oh yeah sorry
I would request a show of hands
therefore those in favor of councilor
Moore
and those in favor of councilor Edward
any extensions
are there any extensions thank you very
much any extensions oh I got some
extensions
nothing okay so um right now here we are
here now please be upstanding whilst the
platform party retires that's us for a
few minutes in order for the chair to be
infested with the chain and Badge of
office
by the way I should mention that
although it seemed fairly obvious
councilor Edward did win
[Music]
Right congratulations councilor Edward I
shall now leave the chamber
pretty interesting
can you just tell him that this whole
reasons
there'll be a short recess while change
are exchanged please be seated
[Music]
foreign
please stand
there we go I called upon the chief
executive
thank you I invite Council Edwards as
the chair for 2023 4 to make the
Declaration of acceptance of office if
you would like to read
look if you read that
oh out loud yes
well before
hi John Edwards
has been elected in the office of
chairman of the thanet district council
declared I take that office upon myself
and will duly and Faithfully fulfill the
duties in the corners with the best of
my judgment and ability thank you
what was that closer to the mic yeah
yeah right and the day is it's the 18th
of May
thank you
okay
thank you Harry
[Music]
give your speech to say thank you and
formalize your escort
I'm not one for making a speech so uh
thank all those people that voted me in
and I think all those that didn't
so your escort is going to be and my
escort will be my lovely wife
Mrs Pat Edwards
I only said that because it's on TV
elections
elections of Vice chairman are there any
nominations
Council Everett
I nominate counselor Deborah Owen Hughes
this is your second
right are there any other nominations
counselor
thank you chair I'll uh go for a second
time I nominate counselor Paul Moore
thank you
all right
I'd like to request a show of hands
those in favor
Owen Hughes
Council a little more and those in favor
of counselor more please raise your hand
any abstentions any abstentions
say
pleased to say that counselor so
Owen Hughes has been elected for the
office of Vice chair of the thank
District Council for the issuing year
before to invite her up
that's it yeah so if we now say this bit
here right
please be upstanding whilst the vice
chair is invested with the badge of
office
do I do that yep yep so that's that
please be seated
and I call upon the chief executive
thank you I invite counselor Owen Hughes
as the vice chair for 2023-24 to make
the Declaration of acceptance of office
counselor would you like to say thank
you
hi Deborah Owen Hughes having been
elected to the office of Vice chair of
thanet District Council declare that I
take that office upon myself and will
Julie and Faithfully fulfill the duties
of it according to the best of my
judgment and ability
tonight
thank you
[Music]
all right councilor Owen Hughes would
you like to say a few words and revise
who will be your escort
I haven't decided who my escort will be
yet but I do thank you for voting for me
and the ones that haven't
[Laughter]
they told me I'd get offers
thank you
right item
agenda item three apologies for absence
uh Council of e s Pugh
are there any other apologies
right agenda item four announcements
I am sad to inform counselors that
formal former councilor Peter Osborne
has passed away
I would ask them just to pause for a
minute silence in respect of councilor
Peter Osborne
thank you
so as a marker respect and gratitude for
their time and efforts as chairman
fanatic District Council presents all of
its former chairs of council with a past
Chairman's badge
former councilor Savage was chairman of
the Sonic visit Council from May 2019
till today
Maya asked him to approach the front
bench and accept his past Chairman's
badge
and our thanks for his service to Senate
District Council
thank you very much indeed Mr chairman
it's been a pleasure to serve this
Council thank you very much
[Applause]
agenda item five Declarations of
Interest
agenda item six that minutes of the
previous meeting
I move that the minutes of the meeting
of the council held on the 30th of March
2023 be approved and signed as a correct
record
with the vice chair please second second
do members agree
thank you
agenda item seven election of leader of
council are there any nominations
oh
right which one do you want to get I
think outside of my head was first right
right
cancel the Whitehead
your nomination please
I normally counselor Rick Everett
is that second dude
right okay
and then Council a cup Council the cup
thank you chair I nominate councilor
Rhys Pugh
a few seconds
right okay so
so
fans well right I would like to request
a show of hands
those in favor of counselor
Everett please raise your hand
s
and then
um those in favor of counselor Pugh I
was in favor of councilor Pugh please
raise your hands
okay and any abstentions any abstentions
oh here the hereby declare that the
counselor Everett has been elected
leader of the scientific Council for the
ensuing year
[Applause]
a cordathon castle over it
thank you chair and thank you members uh
for giving me this responsibility for a
second time
those of you who saw the earlier
installment will know that two things
happened when I assume this role in 2019
first of all there was an early general
election
and secondly there was a global pandemic
some of us quite quite like the first to
happen again but I don't think any of us
won the second to happen again
seriously it's like privilege and an
honor to lead this Council and I will
discharge those responsibilities to the
best of my ability and on behalf of all
members and of all our residents
we didn't have the opportunity to say
this at the count so I want to put on
record my thanks to the election staff
and to the returning officer for their
work leading up to May the 4th and May
the 5th
most of the issues that did come up were
external to the council they were about
voter ID and postal vote delivery but
generally speaking it was a smoothly run
election in difficult circumstances and
of course a very satisfactory result
but I want to say something about a
couple of members who lost their seats
in that election
clearly I am delighted that we won
Westbrook Ward and the chair might look
a bit of scans at me if I wasn't
but I want to say that I took no
personal pleasure whatsoever in
councilor Ashby's defeat
we certainly had our political
differences but I have every respect for
her contribution that she made to this
Council particularly as leader and I
wish her well
at this point I was going to welcome
councilor Pew to his new role but
unfortunately he's unable to be with us
but seriously I do uh welcome to Israel
and I hope that we can have a
constructive a relationship as I have
with Ash behind the scenes at least
secondly the election saw the defeat of
councilor Bob bayford after I think 32
years
unlike some of my predecessors I always
enjoyed sparring with Bob
but more to the point he has given
extraordinary service to this Council
and if he's exit at the hands of the
voters was abrupt
he should at least go with our sincere
thanks for all the work he did over all
those years
[Applause]
we have to look to the Future now
I'm really excited by the quality of
some of our new councilors and I know
that they're going to make a big
contribution in the years ahead
I also welcome back to Labor's ranks
councilor green councilor Edwards
Council of massaface and councilor will
scoby who were all members with me
between 2011 and 2015.
it is a remarkable turnaround to go from
four labor councilors in 2015 to 30
eight years later
the political wheel has turned but more
important the public wants us to deliver
change for Fanny as well
we will work with members from across
the chamber to deliver the change that
they want and I welcome your support in
doing that thank you
thank you
Department of Deputy leader of the
council called upon the newly elected
leader
a councilor Helen Whitehead
I declare that councilor Whitehead has
appointed Deputy leader of the council
[Applause]
so I'll call upon councilor Whitehead
give a speech of thanks
I'm not particularly prepared for a
speech which is unusual for me I think
it's fair to say
um I would like to say that
it was an absolute privilege to serve as
a counselor over the past four years and
to be able to support counselor over it
and
I hope support Planet as a whole
I don't take this responsibility lightly
at all and I look forward to working
together with everyone over the next
four years
thank you
a gender item nine responsibility for
functions executive decisions
or members please refer to supplement
agenda number one
Accord upon the leader
to name the cabinet members
thank you shay as a tech memory test
isn't it the cabinet member responsible
for corporate services will be councilor
Yates the cabinet member for responsible
for regeneration and property will be
councilor Ruth Duckworth
Cabinet member for cleansing and Coastal
services will be counselor Steve Alban
and the cabinet member for housing will
be Helen Whitehead and the cabinet
member for neighborhoods will be at the
Keane thank you
are called upon councilor cup to name
his opposition spokesman
thank you chair uh obviously I'm saying
on behalf of council Depew so the shadow
leader of the council will be councilor
Rhys Pugh the shadow depths leader and
Shadow Cabinet member for regeneration
and property will be councilor George
cupp the shadow Cabinet member for
cleansing and Coastal services will be
councilor Brenda Rogers The Shadow
Cabinet member for corporate services
will be councilor Mark rattigan the
shadow Cabinet member for housing will
be counted your bayford and the shadow
Cabinet member for neighborhoods will be
councilor Sam bambridge thank you chair
thank you
council is asked to receive the cabinet
portfolios company portfolio holders
opposition spokesman portfolio
operational
accountabilities and executive
dedicated functions
that's right right agenda item 10
composition of committees panels and
Boards 20 23 24.
would members please refer to supplement
agenda number one
member number number and size of
committees I move that the number of
committees and the number of members to
serve on those committees are shown in
table two of the report be adopted
with the chair please second
Vice chair I second thank you
do members agree yeah right
right political portrayal
portugality I know that the
profitability would be between groups
for committees panels and boards for 23
24 shown in table three four five and
six of the report be adopted with the
vice chair please adopt second I second
it do members agree
thank you
appointment of independent members of
Standards committee I know that the
council appoints Mr Peter Rosendo as an
independent member of the standards
committee with a i with a term of office
expiring
at the annual council meeting in 2027.
would the vice chair please second I
second chair right the members agree
thank you
nomination of members to serve on
committees the nominations of members to
serve on committers are outlined in
members notes
with the voice chair second seconded to
members agree
questions
election of chair and vice chairs of
committees panels and boards for
2023-24 municipal year I propose that
the following members are elected as
chairs and vice chairs of the Committees
for the 23-24 municipal year
so that's planning chair and Crittenden
OCB Phil fellows OCB Vice chairman David
Green governor and all that will scoby
Governor audit Vice chair Clarissa
Bryant giant Transportation board Jenny
Mata face and general purpose is chair
Harry scoby
would the vice chair please second happy
to second
new members agree
thank you
instead
standards committee and constitutional
review working party I know that Mr
Peter Tucker be appointed chair of the
standards committee and constitutional
review working party and that Peter
lazenzo
be appointed Vice chair of those
standards committee and constitutional
review working party for the ensuring
year with the vice chair please second
seconded do members agree
thank you
agenda item 11 representation of outside
bodies would members please refer to the
members notes for representation of
outside bodies I called upon the leader
thank you chair
um in the notes is the list of executive
and non-executive outside bodies um the
executive outside bodies the list is
agreed by Council and the appointments
are made by cabinet the non-executive
outside bodies the list is agreed by
Council and the appointments are made by
Council names have been put forward and
are contained in the members notes I
moved the two lists and the list of
appointments to the non-executive
outside bodies as presented to council
a call upon a second
Council of open
few members agree
thank you
Council Council that concludes the
business for the annual meeting of the
council
thank you